he's our next guest he's going to join
us very soon at the table he's a
four-time Oscar nominee Willem Dafoe is
his name he has more than
140 screen credits including familiar
movies like we remember platoon at
eternity's gate Spider-Man no way home
we all remember these movies his new
project is the psychological drama it's
called Inside So Defoe stars is Nemo an
art Thief who finds himself in a fight
for survival after breaking goes bad and
then he's trapped in the Manhattan
penthouse yikes in this preview Nemo
befriends a pigeon outside the window
and ask it to find him some help
tell him
that I'm stuck here
no one's come
do that for me
nobody here but us pigeons
right
tortoise it's so good Willem Dafoe is
with us first on CBS mornings it's so
good to have you in the studio at the
table I'll just say what Brian you met
Brian earlier our stage manager he said
Willem Dafoe is just good in everything
he really is isn't that good you're just
good in everything thank you Brian that
was Brian who said it will Defoe he's
just good in everything so let's talk
about inside because number one you're
in every single scene in this movie uh
you're by yourself in this movie yeah so
you read the script and you think I
gotta do this what attracted you to this
a basic premise I really liked it and I
knew certain things like we were going
to shoot in chronological order that's
unusual shooting in chronological it is
um and also like you know when you have
an expansive role you can really
participate in making the movie on the
day sometimes when you have a a shorter
role or a little character role you have
to
serve a function yeah but this you
really can sit in it and you can go deep
but how do you even prepare though will
and when you're it's just you yourself
and you this was odd you don't because
the story really starts out with uh the
guy being trapped in there and that's
where the story starts and it doesn't
really matter where he was before at
least I didn't feel the need to create a
backstory because he's dealing with
stuff immediately and the characters
really revealed through yes what happens
to them yeah so we should set up he goes
to Rob this Penthouse of artwork right
the the system goes uh haywire and
you're literally trapped computer
doesn't work the door doesn't work the
phone doesn't work there's no
electricity there's no water there's no
food and it's just you in this gorgeous
apartment nobody's coming and nobody and
nobody nobody's system didn't alert them
yes yes so it's uh challenging so it
becomes a little bit of a game too also
for the audience because you're trying
to figure out how to overcome these
obstacles I honestly didn't know how it
was going to end either psychologically
and you're shooting in chronological
order and and your character goes slowly
somewhat uh deteriorates yeah well he
goes inside
he goes inside he goes and he starts to
ask himself certain questions about his
uh about life yeah about life yes what
was it like doing that I mean and this
is a pleasure you know
um it was it was it's a difficult movie
to do but a fun movie to do and uh
something about once you
the thing takes a rhythm it gets a it
has a rhythm of its own and it just
propels you and uh you show up every day
you enter this monolocal there's no
natural light you time gets bent you're
really there with problems and actions
and these kind of meditations that
naturally spring out of his situation so
um you problem solve as an actor you
problem solved to see uh you know work
with the director and everyone else to
find the best shots and all that sort of
thing and then you just uh do you do you
do you do and then it works on you and
then you haven't experienced that
hopefully is transparent enough that the
audience is with you and participating I
think you just Channel your inner Willem
Dafoe I can do it yes um okay a few
things one that's a glorious mustache uh
you know what this is for something else
I would never wear this for life oh
that's what I'm shooting now
100 it looks good Joe
staliness that's a compliment um second
thing the fact that it is just you and
this movie shows how extremely talented
you are you are one of the most personal
talents in the business yeah you guys
are embarrassing
would you rather we say you suck right
no don't keep it going and lastly
um the title of the movie Inside yeah it
can be interpreted uh many different
ways as you watch this movie and like
you said that the character goes kind of
inside himself one what did you take
away after completing this project
because I always feel like actors learn
a little bit more about themselves after
they're done yes sir uh it's interesting
because in the in the process of the The
Narrative Arc you start to ask your
questions about your relationship to the
dark side of luxury to uh to Art to what
do you need in this life what's what's
most important uh and because I
I start to interact with the art there's
lots of interesting questions that uh
what is the function of art is it
useless uh is it useful uh can it
elevate things and it's not academic
these kind these things kind of happen
very naturally and the thing that I like
is
it really is a movie that has a strong
Action Line to it you know as a thriller
but at the same time there's also these
meditative things that come up in the
audience they're going to bring their
questions to it or interpretation this
will evoke certain things in them so
we'll see maybe I'm just being
optimistic but I think it's strong and
it's uh
can I just say we're glad you're here
and we can't wait to see in Spider-Man
again okay whatever
that doesn't sound like an indoors oh no
no oh listen listen
I don't know how to if the money's right
I'll be there okay inside we'll be in
theaters don't work like that
hard will be in theaters everywhere on
March 17th with a great Willem Dafoe
thanks a lot